town is transportation private air
transportation we fly the smallest
turboprop airplane to the largest
Gulfstream 550
anything in client wants to do any
destination that company and I both have
an obligation to provide a flight
whatever they want the flight I've been
a pilot since I was 18 years old I
learned to fly it be a very import that
I opened down there at so I bought an
airplane in the year 2000 I said to
myself well maybe I want to make some
income with this airplane rather leave
and sit around so much talent era
started it didn't have an office and we
had first year sales of twenty five
thousand dollars charter is difficult
because the clientele for charter is a
narrow and of people it's not enough to
just look at the charter market because
the competition for the few clients is
very fierce
I've spent endless thousands of hours
trying to figure out what I could do
what I could offer heard to me that
charter clients who converted by one or
two airplanes that clients with multiple
airplanes don't like to pay five six
figures a month to maintain that
airplane just for the privilege of
flying it when they want to i've
innovated this aspect of airplane
ownership and no one else does it which
allows them give me the airplane i take
care of all the bills they fly it for
basically the price of gas and they're
not otherwise responsible for the cost
of maintenance
I take the risk if I charter the
airplane and I keep it moving then I'm
successful I cover my cost if I don't
charter the air but it doesn't move and
I have to pay for it and people love
that I actually didn't occur to me that
talent air would be anything as big as
it is I don't know if I thought it would
do 1 million in sales let alone 60
million at sale going on 125 million
dollars which is about 124 million nine
hundred thousand dollars more than I
ever imagined I might have